program launching in San Francisco will
guarantee income for dozens of
transgender people for a year and a half
tonight ABC 7 news reporter Tim Johns
explores the first of its kind
Initiative for a community that is
oftentimes left behind
for some of the most forgotten people in
our community a Lifeline could soon be
coming from the city of San Francisco
forgotten people in San Francisco I
lived in San Francisco 25 years ago to
20 years ago what about the homeless
people and yeah talk about forgotten
okay and trans people gay people naked
people they have been running the show
there for decades even long before I got
there so let's not pretend that San
Francisco owes them anything or that
they are the most forgotten listen to
this propaganda [ __ ] it is simply
not true that is the place to go to be
yourself literally I they have parades
where you can run around the streets
[ __ ] ass naked okay no worries about it
nothing I have photos we had me and
Daddy have to dig out our own photo
albums and show you some of the parades
they were young people we you know
whatever we were not you know we were
try that in Dubai see how it goes I mean
and so they're acting like this
community has been marginalized in San
Francisco and it is a bold-faced lie oh
yeah that's like the last place to
complain about I feel like anyway go
ahead so let's see what's while while
crime and homelessness are rampant and
it has turned into a filthy Cesspool of
a city let's solve this problem and what
is twelve hundred dollars a month gonna
do in San Francisco buy you a [ __ ]
latte on Wednesday the mayor's office
announced a new effort to combat poverty
among transgender residents this is the
first uh guaranteed income program
for Trans people in the country day one
of being a girl and I have already cried
three times I wrote a scathing email
that I did not send I ordered dresses
online that I couldn't afford and then
uh when someone asked me how this seems
like a joke like this seems like a joke
making fun of women that they cry all
the time order dumb [ __ ] right it's it's
the worst characteristics of a girl who
has no control over herself and has is
never going to amount to anything in
life that's what they do so yeah there
are women like that out there girls like
that out there but it is
characterization right a character what
am I trying you know yeah how are there
no gender roles but then the second you
become a girl now you're crying and
ordering clothes thought it didn't
matter right yeah it doesn't matter
women are okay I'm fine equal when I
wasn't fine how'd I do ladies good the
initiative is called gifts and will give
55 people 1200 a month for 18 months the
program has been years in the making and
is a partnership between local
government lion Martin Community Health
Services and the transgender District
but activists hope the gift program is
only the first step in helping a
community in need statistics show that
trans people this dude went to school to
learn how to broadcast and this is the
[ __ ] he's covering the trans 1200 a
month Bill and it looks he literally
looks like he just fell off a Fox News
truck that's just a funny thing so for
this proportion definitely from things
like poverty discrimination and abuse
the U.S transgender survey which is the
only why not just give it to the poor
people then if you're that worried about
it why does it have to be the transport
people or trans people that make money
they may not even need it it doesn't
even say that they need it it's just
because they're disproportionately like
disproportionate what do you say what
[ __ ] disproportionately lower income
he didn't say that I thought he said
some [ __ ] like that I'm like
marginalized oh marginalized but such a
it wasn't the word they used for
whatever they were they used that's what
the Matrix uses to hold you down calling
you marginalized you know like when you
go to the gym and you're like I'm gonna
do 10 reps and then you get to that 10
and you're like oh I realistically could
have done more but because I told myself
10 I'm gonna stop like that's what it
does it's just a mental block that they
tell people when you're marginalized
you're just constantly hitting this
mental roadblock rather than if you know
you said that was way up higher there
wasn't one in the first place you would
be able to actually amount to such
greater things you're so right I mean
you know gender dysphoria again is uh is
a mental just don't out of the bottle
you can get a glass no no you're not
drinking out of the bottle like an
animal no we don't drink out of
containers in this house no that's mine
get a glass we pour our beverages fill
your [ __ ] up into a nice glass why these
people and it is just a political Ploy
you know to get us all to act like this
is normal behavior I wonder where the
money's going it's uncommon Behavior it
doesn't mean we shouldn't be kind to
them we should be nice to these people
we should be kind and accepting of
everybody where the money is coming from
they said it's a it's a partnership
between the state and these two other
org or the city and these two other
organizations that are one was a
transgender district and one of them was
another non-profit so they're raising
funds for this so I don't know how much
of it is coming out of tax dollars in
order to qualify individuals can be
making no more than six hundred dollars
a month applications for those
potentially eligible are open through
okay 18th with priority given to trans
people of color
welcomes by transact did that just say
trans but white not for you please buy
back up okay applications open transmit
white no twelve hundred dollars this
seems like a joke it's actually real
right so yeah so I got caught on what he
said before that people making 600 a
month or less so like true that I mean
there's nowhere in America that that's
not extreme poverty so in San Francisco
you can't even afford to be homeless on
600 a month it's just the reality right
so if they're giving them twelve hundred
dollars again there are children living
in cars whose parents and I don't see
them making putting that on the news
maybe they are and I'm just missing it
what is this what is this have you seen
this flag I didn't even realize that
this meant like black Trans for a while
but what is what's up with this like why
do I see this flag everywhere well is it
black so are the black and brown stripes
for black and brown trans people or just
black and brown people in general no
it's a black it's a black LGBT flag so
what does that maybe like
0.05.1 maybe of the population and I see
this every everywhere and the funny
thing is they don't even support this
[ __ ] no they don't like I'm just being
generally generally the black community
is just like that this is some [ __ ]
like imagine they did this with the
Italian flag that's what I'm like what
what do they do like why are they doing
this to black people I just don't
understand like why are they picking
them to shove all this [ __ ] down there
like their throats too it's not even
just I think they're just trying to take
all these people all different people
however many they can victimize them and
then get them all together so they can
all cry together and I'll and I'll say
that America is a terrible place
together that's what they're trying to
do and I don't understand why they
wouldn't do that why they wouldn't say
if you think that somebody is like kind
of you have something in common you go
to them and be like hey you want to like
Droid forces and do some you know show
everybody how freaking awesome we are
instead of sitting and going you want to
come cow we're in that corner with me
and cry about everything that we don't
have that's what they do there's just
the victimhood gross ew victimhood is so
gnarly and so unattractive as a quality
in a human being and people that
advocate hate for victimhood you're not
you know what you know what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is what it is
so good in this country so goddamn good
and in most in all First World countries
that people need something there's a
there's a natural inborn Primal need to
accomplish and to feel useful there
really is and you would think that you
know that wasn't coming out because so
many people are so lazy but in order to
feel useful you want to feel like you
really made a difference somewhere and
so these people instead of going out and
solving real problems in order to feel
good about themselves and feel like
their life is worth something you make
up problems they're making up problems
and they're victimizing people so that
then they can go save them I'm gonna
push you off a cliff and then I'm gonna
run run down to the bottom of the clip
and and blow up a mattress and so you
can an air mattress so you can land on
that that's what they're doing to these
people except they're not getting to the
bottom of the cliff and saving them
they're just pushing everybody off a
cliff is really what's really happening
here yeah for real I think that when we
lift those people up the people who are
you know at the bottom of the totem pole
then everyone benefits mahogany says
city has long been a place of Refuge for
transgender people she fears that as a
wave of anti-trans legislation sweeps
protect trans youth oh my that's crazy
protect youth cross out the trans and
just protect the kids protect them
getting mutilated you you switch this up
here so protect the youth from like
that's that's Madness that they're
pushing for like kids under 18 to
actually get this [ __ ] right instead of
instead of just pushing for kids to have
to get treatment emotional mental
treatment that says hey you know what
you're okay how you are when you're
older you know let's continue this
conversation and we'll talk about it
when you're older they're literally
going in and cutting off body parts have
I talked to you about nullification no
what is that uh you can Google it
nullification is when you have your
whatever sexual body parts you have
whether boobs male parts female parts
and you take it all off and it's just
kind of smoothed out and you are just
left with some place to urinate from but
you basically look like a Barbie doll
she'll get that done that's what
nullification is so that not you're not
going from complete [ __ ] lunatics
that's who so you're not going from male
to female or female to male you're going
to completely uh gender neutral
physically you know what my favorite
analogy is is if you want to cut off
your arm and become like what's well I
don't even know what the word would be
disabled yeah to say like if you just
want to become disabled and you want to
cut off your arm why is that a mental
disorder but wanting to chop your dick
off isn't it
literally nipples everything just
becomes smooth but from here it's like
that the way they say like men and women
are the same there's no gender roles
then like why can't you just live as a
as the other gender and still be a guy
like what does it matter well it is
funny how they yeah they want to start
or am I missing something there yeah it
doesn't connect I don't know legislation
sweeps parts of the country programs
like these will become even more
critical for people who simply have
nowhere else to go it's really really
important that we figure out ways to
welcome even the rainbow box
able to help stabilize them and make
sure that they don't end up on the
streets in San Francisco Tim Jones what
is twelve hundred dollars even gonna do
though in in San Francisco the shittiest
apartment you can get in the [ __ ] and
the legit [ __ ] is like 3 000. what
like what is twelve hundred dollars
gonna do and then if you get a job you
probably lose that twelve hundred
dollars so they're incentivized to stay
to stay brockies I hate San Francisco I
think that's one of the shittiest places
in the country I'm not even a lot it
used it is still excuse me
geographically absolutely beautiful our
um architecturally it's beautiful smells
like pee though but there was there was
yeah human feces NP on even in the
nicest neighborhoods all over the place
it's it's a shame day 66 being a girl
and today I'm in nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them no this is a joke imagine well you
know magic this is that guy this is the
guy that met with the president hey Matt
yeah imagine this person has just been
playing like a joke the whole time to
show how stupid oh yeah no I think I
think he's wearing heels we talked about
that into the woods I said he was
sitting around a campfire with his Bros
getting high and he was like dudes
imagine how funny that would be how
funny it would be if I thought dot dot
and look at them now like that to me
that's the only plausible explanation 74
being a girl Round of Applause for the
makeup and I wore this outfit shopping
today and I thought that these might be
my new shopping shorts but I was walking
around and everyone was staring and I
was like oh okay what's going on and
they were all staring directly at my
crotch and I went oh I forgot that my
crotch doesn't look like other women's
crotches sometimes because you're not a
woman doesn't look like a little Barbie
pocket women having bulges sometimes
because we're coming up on bikini season
baby and you might see a bulge or two so
normalize the Bulge we are normalizing
the ball no way this is real
holy [ __ ] I cannot believe this is real
how many followers does this mafika have
on Tick Tock how many followers does
this pumpkin have holy [ __ ] 9.9 million
followers uh but what and then another
thing what's up with the why is she they
like why yeah I'm referring to you as
like she but then when I have to use the
her or possessive I have to use the
plural like it's it's just like it makes
such little sense at this point it
genuinely seems like a prank it he's
wrapped at CAA look business the agent's
name is at creative artist agency one of
the largest agencies on Earth talent
agencies oh yeah CAA is huge so it's a
it's a big deal
you know I'm like I'm like a big Tick
Tock marketer and stuff how funny would
it be if I did this it went viral and
just made like 100 Grand off of brand
deals and like you guys would just keep
it on the down low you wouldn't say it's
me and we all it was just like a big
prank that we were all playing together
what's your name gonna be Seraphina
Seraphina indeed have to be or Sonia no
Seraphina it's the way to go oh my God
this is unbelievable the Bulge I
wondered why people were looking at my
bulge or why they were looking at me
well one year a tick tock star maybe
that and also because like like you
don't so you're running around in
leather Shores how do you forget to do
your grocery shopping with it with full
makeup how do you forget you have a dick
though how like how does it I've never
just been like oh there I forgot you
were there he doesn't forget he knows
fully well what he's got it's a prank
carrying around tampons and pads but
I've actually never opened one up so
let's do it you I thought the letter
stood for small medium and large based
on the size of your Barbie pouch but
after a Google I found out it's actually
even I knew that glow so they're super
super light I guess my question is which
one do I carry around the super because
maybe if you have a light flow you can
still use a super I don't know you'll
never need to know you'll never need to
know I was just thinking the same thing
unless your butthole starts bleeding I
can't stand it I just what the [ __ ] you
don't understand what it was like to
grow up in the 80s be a teenager in the
90s back in my day normal [ __ ] people
running around and crazy people were
crazy people and all we were taught was
just be nice to them just be nice to
people yeah it's because except people
you don't have to be like them we all
don't have to be the same I want to look
at the bottle no go get a glass
that is uh it's something and you know
like the thing is too like when I talk
to trans people in person and stuff like
no they're perfectly nice people a lot
of the time it creates lunatics like
this that are the face of the whole
they're hurting those people exactly
they're legit hurting they're ruining it
for them ruin it for everybody yeah our
trans people or cool man they were fine
fine I remember when you were little we
were on the subway in Boston one day and
there was a dude in a dress and you just
kind of like
you were just quiet and looking and I
see a lot of weird [ __ ] in the city and
I can't remember exactly what happened I
think you said after like you like man
and I was like yeah it was a man and
he's wearing a dress and some some men
do that and it's okay like it's just it
is what it is and you were like okay and
that was the whole conversation wasn't
he has a penis and you know if if you
don't like your penis which you don't
even know is for then maybe we'll we'll
cut it off yeah if you want to play with
dolls you know we can do it like do you
think you like to wear a dress that's
funny because we can we can go shopping
we're on the subway let's go downtown
let's see how you feel with it yeah
let's go feel how you feel in a dress no
like none of that [ __ ] even crossed my
Minds like yes he's wearing a dress yeah
it is what it is some people do that
what are you gonna do all right well
that was horrible horrible thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe follow me on Instagram
sunnyfaz yeah we want to hear your
thoughts in the comments I want to know
what you guys think about uh Dylan
Mulvaney do you think he's real or do
you think he was a bro sitting around a
campfire who decided to play a trick on
the world because it's got to be a trip
I really am leaning toward it's a trick
on the world because for him to be that
ridiculous it's just too much much for
me too much from my brain
[Music]
[Music]